hi all today we are going to talk about
a subject that usually does not get the
attention you deserve money why because
if you wish your startup to last
it must be profitable there's no other
way and you should think of your
business funds as air as long as you
have enough of it you don't have to
think about it at all
but the minute you run out of it it's
game over I mean the green and in the
past 20 years I've started six companies
two companies were acquired one became
profitable and three flew into a wall
just like Buzz Lightyear currently I'm
having fun at Google as a developer
advocate helping startups and developers
get the most out of monetization and I'm
Jess a program manager and course
developer here at Udacity my role in
this course is to ask questions
questions of IDO on how we monetize and
questions of you to help you start
thinking about how you'll apply what you
learn here in your own product in this
course you'll learn basic monetization
principles for a variety of product
types how to implement these strategies
and how to track their effectiveness
let's take a little look at how we'll do
this